here's a lady right here that's got
something so here's a little
dime here's a little brother shout out
culture corner
um i've got a bit of a different type of
submission for you today
uh my name is tessie by day i am a
marketing coordinator website designer
and housewife and dog mom but on the
weekends i sometimes like to pull out a
little alter ego i like to call jesse
james
and i have been a stripper for seven
years
so i decided to bring that big hitter
that thick boy anthem
to cleveland and i'm going to have to
have you can you sting it what do you
think of my thick boy
anthem music video and i know everyone
might be a little bit hesitant
on strippers on the show after baby
unique but
trust me let it ride and just cheer me
out on this
um gang gang big butts
damn daddy okay so she's a dancer huh
every bit
cheat got the thick peach in the back
[Music]
is this atlanta or some [ __ ] cleveland
[Music]
there's a lesbian out there snacking who
snacks at the strip club
yeah boy that pipe is loose huh
yeah i think wiggles room damn she's
nice with that pole though
that one of those tall ones sure that
one stripper fell off the top rack
that was too far before he's got a
three-story falling
broker she broke her hip i think they
buried her under this oh [ __ ]
oh she's going definitely man she's
leaving the building
he's leaving the building
[Music]
little brown's gonna be pumped
[Music]
damn cleveland lit as [ __ ]
oh this is beautiful man look i love
seeing women get out there and do their
thing
make that money girl down get out i
think boy anthem got them fans riled up
to start throwing that cash
well this is the original only fans is
this was it it was in a it was in a
broken water building man yeah and so
i'll say this man is yeah get out there
and do it
get them cheeks out cfc's not ashamed to
see how she's touching that top rope
deal yeah i see it that could be you man
looking right at it that could be you
look at her that ain't gonna be me ass
up face down
dude game son i don't want that man i
can barely get through what i'm doing
now
yeah it'd be tough to get up that paul
i'm not gonna lie to you guys yeah
and i just switched to uh symbols whoa
oh i thought she fell i was like oh we
don't want that she did fall
but she put the brakes oh look at her go
whoa
she got the cakes with the brakes homie
takes your breaks
that'd be my strip club cakes and breaks
and they do uh they do brake pads but
they also have ass
yeah and cakes she's kicked the [ __ ]
up son okay brendan you told us that but
here's what i'm distracting
here's what i'm saying is this man this
girl obviously is doing her best
i when i'm really good at it she got
four dollars she had four bucks
oh well hold on once she starts shaking
that ass it seems
the video cut off too soon yeah we
should venmo her 40 man i'll tell her
40.
yeah i'll give another 40. so what i
would like to think about is
that um with the town i grew up in at a
strip club it wasn't like a club but it
was like you could strip in there and
people were
if you wanted to they had it available
people were doing it these are dicey
and the problem was the pole was actual
plumbing so every now and then you would
hear somebody upstairs [ __ ]
flush a dump and it would come right
down right down the stripper pole dude
so somebody would be spinning on this
thing and everything
you know you would hear a flush running
through bro
and that's christ baby it's a great use
of space though
look you it's like very and i don't want
to point fingers but it's very you know
where
japanese oh okay all right i didn't know
that
dude japanese will sleep in the they'll
sleep in the back pocket yeah you know
what i'm saying if it makes sense yeah
you've got enough pockets
logistically though you'll see a
japanese guy open up a coat pocket
jump in there and go to bed you know
what i'm saying like they are so
organized
smart there's no wasting time shout out
to that young thickie man
love the thick boy anthem